sobre el territorio de taiwán y su
estatus en el tablero internacional pese
a la ambigüedad
es un territorio independiente de facto
con su propia constitución y un sistema
democrático liberal aunque solo lo
reconoce en 15 países
el resto incluido eeuu interlocutar
oficialmente solo con china que
considera a taiwán parte de su
territorio nacional el divorcio empezó
en
1949 cuando mouse de don ganó la guerra
civil en china y el gobierno derrocado
se replegó en taiwán desde la isla se
reivindicaron como gobierno único chino
y apostaron por reconquistar el
territorio continental durante décadas
sin embargo el gobierno actuar en taiwán
tiene otros planes busca abiertamente la
independencia y sigamos esforzándonos en
proteger nuestra patria una línea roja
que beijing no está dispuesta a cruzar
bajo ningún concepto
de hecho aprobó una ley que le permite
usar métodos no pacíficos y taiwán
intentará independizarse con un ejército
de unos 300.000 efectivos en la isla
sería un combate de david contra goliat
y precisamente por eso eeuu se
comprometió a garantizar la capacidad de
defensa militar de taiwán
washington vende armas con regularidad a
taipei y bailén incluso admitió que
estaría dispuesto y militarmente
siquiera invadir el territorio algo
contradictorio con la política de una
sola china que la casa blanca dice
defender
si nadie quiere que estalle en problemas
en el estrecho definitivamente no el
presidente bailen
seguimos comprometidos con nuestra
política de una sola china y
continuaremos ayudando a taiwán con la
capacidad que necesita para defenderse
ahora la visita de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi a
taiwán hace peligrar el delicado
equilibrio logrado con esta diplomacia
ambigua y amenaza con devolver el
conflicto al estrecho de taiwán la
franja de mar de 180 kilómetros de media
que separa la isla del continente y por
donde pasan la mitad de los barcos
comerciales del mundo